Yeah.
So don't be thinking that the things that appeared in front of you are merely
objects because they're not,
you know,
I started thinking about this for example,
when I was thinking about people going down to Graceland to look at Elvis
Guitar,
you think,
what exactly is it that makes a guitar Elvis and his guitar?
You know,
it's not exactly the guitar because it's just sitting there like any old guitar,
you know,
and maybe you could even think about it.
You could take that and guitar out and he could put another guitar in that look
just like it and it would still be all of us as guitar cause no one would know.
And you might think,
well then that's not really,
Elvis has guitar.
But that's a funny thing because you would only think that if you thought that
Elvis is guitar was the thing that was made out of material that was sitting
right in front of you.
And that isn't what it is.
That's only one tiny little bit of it.
That bloody thing is,
is a part of an incredibly layered reality.
Right?
I mean,
the people who want to go look at that,
they're looking at it in some sense because of the magic that's emanating from
it.
But the magic is actually real.
You know,
the magic is the effect of that guitar,
let's say,
on the entire culture.
And those effects are the damn guitar too.
And it's weird because when you go look at Elvis Guitar,
you don't have looking at the guitar,
you're looking at the magic.
And weirdly enough,
the magic is actually real.
Well,
you can't think that way if you're a materialist because you think that the
thing is the material.
It's like,
yeah,
right.
I can tell you another story.
So when the,
when the Europeans came to the South Pacific islands,
the South Pacific islanders,
because there weren't that many of them,
they didn't have a very high,
highly technical society,
you know?
And so like if you were like Joe Dominant guy in a Pacific island culture,
you know,
you might be able to have a stone ax,
like a well made stone ax because going make a stone ax and see how long that
takes you.
It's like,
oh,
that's a bit of work.
And so if you're a high status guy,
if you've really worked your whole life to be at the top of your Damn pyramid,
you get,
maybe you get head to access.
You know,
it's like a red letter day.
You've got two axes,
you know,
which is more than any other animal has by a lot.
So it's not trivial.
And then the damn missionaries come in and they,
and they set up shop and what do they bring?
Steel axes.
It's like that's kind of a downer.
You know,
you've worked your whole damn life to get these stone axes and that makes you
like head tribesmen and then you want your kid wanders down to the local
missionaries and they say,
hey,
we got an extra steel ax here.
Why don't you take that back home?
And it's like,
it's so shocking because not only did the missionaries have this thing that is
so much better than a steel ax,
it's like a jet plane compared to a,
yeah,
to a wheeled cart.
Like they're really,
really different.
But the missionaries,
they don't even notice.
That's the horrible thing about it.
It's like the giveaway,
this thing that hasn't been virtually infinite value,
and it's like,
well,
it's okay.
We got,
you know,
a couple dozen of those sitting in the store room and you know,
we're just willing to hand them out.
It was a little demoralizing.
It was a little demoralizing for the Pacific Islanders,
and so,
you know,
why was it an ax that the missionaries gave away?
It wasn't.
You'd think that if you are a Westerner and you had a bunch of access,
it's like,
yeah,
that's an ax.
It's like,
yeah,
right.
It's a lot more than an ax,
a lot more.
It's a weapon to bring down a whole culture accidentally.